islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
defense before i start one praise allah
the most merciful the most stressed or
praise his glory and gratitude belong to
him will smith's wife she's forced to
wear the hijab but why now provinces as
you can see i'm in turkey i'm living in
large you know as you can see louis
vuitton no i think it's but not burberry
burberry as you can see guys but it's a
fake uh original fake usually i'll go
and ask them is this fake brother they
say no it's not fake it's original fake
uh so anyways i needed a scarf i bought
this for 30 pounds uh it's quite a nice
nice material as well anyways it's not
the topic here uh just made that clear
just in case you guys think i'm living a
lavish life uh sadly not well yeah in a
fake way anyways let's get straight into
the topic brothers and sisters now allah
when he talks about in the quran when he
commanded the sky in the heavens he said
come together willingly or unwillingly
and they said we come willingly
now the question that we need to ask
here and the main topic is willingly and
willingly brothers and sisters there are
certain things that lost a panel without
ask us to do willingly because we are
human beings and we have the free will
to do to choose or not to choose the
animals are not like that neither are
the angels the injured as they're told
the animals act based on instinct so the
question here is this
willingly or unwillingly there are
certain things allah subhanahu wa tala
will tell us not to do no drink alcohol
don't commit to dinner don't commit
murder don't gamble now we would either
do this willingly or one day be forced
to do it unwillingly
and in that very instance maybe we won't
even get the rewards because we were
forced into it will smith's wife has
come and we saw this about a year ago
where smart agenda covered the videos of
her wearing hijab
now we came to know from this video
which we're gonna watch right now and
come back and we're gonna discuss this a
little further getting a lot of
questions about
why i've been wearing this turban yeah
well
i've been having issues with hair loss
and i'm gonna tell you it was terrifying
when it when it first started you know i
was in the shower one day and then just
handfuls of hair just in my hands and i
was just like oh my god am i going bald
it was one of those times in my life
where i was literally shaking with fear
even in my terror and even in my fear
and in the moment of just going oh my
god like
why are you so terrified that you might
lose your hair right
i really had to put it on a spiritual
perspective of like
the higher power takes so much from
people
people are out here who have cancer
people who have sick children i watch
the higher power take things every day
and by golly if the high priest wants to
take your hair
that's it
god you want my hair
when i looked at it from that
perspective it really did settle me so
in that video you saw guys she's talking
about losing hair and she's saying that
her daughter is actually in tears
because as a woman they know how
terrifying that is for because a woman
loves attention you know she likes to
beautify herself etc you know and this
is the fitness that our sisters face
sadly um but the point here is this
she's there and she's saying that she
would get bundles of hair falling out
and she goes i was terrified but there's
something she says which i admired
because in that very instance she said
that when she thought about because the
prophet peace be upon him said to us
that when you're looking at people don't
look at the people that on top of you
what have things that you don't have
because you'll be ungrateful allah look
at those that don't have what you have
been grateful to him i feel as if she
applied the hadith in that moment where
she said god almighty could have she was
talking about god with a high power
could have taken a lot of things like
you know give cancer et cetera your
health if it's going to be my health
i submit my will like let it be the hair
and to me that was a form of submission
like allah said to the bidders in the
quran that they say we've come to
believe they said don't say we've come
to believe but say we have submitted i'm
not saying these are the same things
with the will smith's wife but the point
is this now she has to
wear the hijab in that context or or a
turban or some sort of a thing you know
and maybe inshallah this would be reason
for it to come to islam maybe i don't
know the point is the following and i'm
not i'm gonna wrap up inside we're gonna
keep it too long inshallah is the
following sisters yeah my dear sisters
and this goes for brothers as well but
we're speaking about a female here is
this
you can either cover up willingly
unwillingly so don't let the day that
you die be the day that you're shrouded
uncovered finally you know
and
the point here is this brother and
sisters especially sisters as well is
that in this very instance like there
was a man
who
migrated for the sake of a woman and the
process said we know the hadith
that the one who migrates or does
something for the sake of allah will be
rewarded for that and the one who
migrates for a woman or whatever it may
be then there is no rule in the context
where because you are traveling just for
that however you can have double
intentional scholars have talked about
is that you can do both you know i'm
traveling for the sake of allah to not
commit zina to get married to get
married that woman it can be both his
world my point is this she is now
unwillingly
having to cover her hair not in a
religious sense but my dear sisters the
point that i'm trying to make is that
don't let it be that that day because we
even have sisters who wear the hijab but
they're not doing it for the sake of
allah you will not be getting rewarded
you will repeat again you will not be
getting rewarded if you are wearing the
hijab for a fashion sense or to look
good because allah would ask you what
did you do oh where the hijab no you
didn't wear the hijab for my sake you
were because of fashion reason
fashion uh reasons or fashion or
whatever it may be so my point is let's
just render intentions and for those who
are wearing the hijab for fashion
reasons doesn't mean take you off renew
your intentions and say oh allah i'm
going to try to do this for your sake as
well
that's the message i wanted to share
inshallah and we're here hopefully learn
a lesson from will smith's wife um and
make some changes and this goes for both
brothers and sisters in a nutshell till
next time salaam alaikum warahmatullahi